apple is apparently working on a 12.9 in
iPad Air which sounds absolutely nuts
like my voice cuz I'm sick don't mind it
the 12.9 in air sounds nuts because it's
always com in just one size but even
crazier it's rumored to be coming sooner
than you think but the big question I'm
going to focus on in this video is why
why in the world do we need another iPad
model in the lineup which is already all
over the place and confusing as it is
but Apple's apparently going to make it
even more complicated so I've been
giving this some thought and trying to
match it up to some other iPad leaks and
rumors and I think I found the answer so
buckle up because this gets very
interesting and also a little bit
disappointing remember those leaks from
last year about Apple working on a 14-in
iPad well according to Mark Gman Apple
actually got really close to releasing
it this year but they cancelled sold it
why probably because the upcoming iPad
Pro Models are rumored to come in 11 and
13in sizes so a 14-in non-pro iPad would
have made everything a chaotic mess but
now we recently got a very convincing
leak hinting at two new iPad a models in
the works especially since 95 Max
sources discovered two iPad code names
j53 7 and J5 38 which apparently are
based on the iPad Air and yes those code
names are completely different from the
newly discovered code names for the
small and large iPad Pro Models leaked
code names always end up being the
models that we see released next and yes
Mark German did say that the new iPad
air is coming soonish likely released
via a press release instead of an event
and then just the other day we got the
huge new report from Digi times claiming
that the 12.9 in iPad air is coming and
that it for sure will not feature a mini
LED display which makes sense because
that Tech is meant for the Pro Models
now realistically if Apple did have both
a 10.9 in and 12.9in iPad Air they would
likely have identical specs with the
only real difference being the display
size and maybe the speaker quality and
according to digi times production will
begin in early 2024 at the latest and
with no delays in November so I have a
good feeling that this new iPad Air will
be coming sometime between next month
and the spring of 2024 so with all that
said it's becoming clear that a 12.9 in
iPad air is coming but now let's get to
the original question why well I believe
we actually have to look towards Apple's
future iPad lineup which will start to
form next year specifically starting
with the new 2024 iPad Pro we've been
getting lots and lots of reports over
the the past year or even more that we
should expect a major redesign for the
first time since the 2018 iPad Pro which
was a massive redesign everything was
changed we had the apple pencil 2 the
flat sides it was completely different
and it was so awesome and this time
around we're also going to be getting
the Magic Pencil 3 with potentially
magnetic tips we're getting the new M3
chip on 3 nanomer we've had reports of
Max safe reverse w L charging support
we've also had reports of a major
redesign for the magic keyboard Now
featuring an aluminum top case which is
going to make it a lot more premium more
like a Macbook in terms of the quality
and the design it's basically going to
be the biggest redesign since 2018 and
it's going to be a big deal but the
biggest new rumored feature of all is
the new OLED display which is going to
be the big thing for this new update so
why why did Apple not do OLED before
well the issue with OLED is that a lot
of them are very very dim the displays
sometimes limit out to 400 to 500 nits
on larger tablet displays and that's
exactly why Apple chose mini LED instead
because it can go up to 1,600 nits but
this new OLED display is actually using
brand new tech it's basically going to
have a tandem stack hybrid OLED design
it's basically going to be the Best of
Both Worlds you're going to have the
best contrast ratios like from OLED
displays with no halo effect but you're
going to have that super high brightness
up to 1,600 nits probably on these new
ones it's essentially going to be the
best tablet display ever created the
only issue is the price rumors are going
around that it's going to start at
potentially
$1,500 for the base 11.1 in model which
is insane and
$1,800 for the 13-in iPad Pro Model
that's basically almost a doubling of
price for the base 11 in and it sounds
absolutely crazy but the Ola Tech is
going to be extremely expensive and
that's why the price has to be that high
and maybe on top of that apple is
planning a lot of big updates that we're
not even expecting just yet maybe
they're going to make iPad OS more like
Mac OS than ever before or maybe even
give Mac OS to these high-end iPad Pros
exclusively which is something I argued
against in the past but maybe at such a
high price point they'll actually offer
it I don't know but here is the big
issue with this new expensive iPad Pro
the current iPad Air cost $600 so if
there is going to be a
$1,500 iPad Pro who in their right mind
would pay 2.5 times more cash when they
can simply go with an iPad Air for for a
relatively similar experience well that
is exactly where I believe the 12.9 in
iPad Pro comes in if Apple does in fact
raise the base price of the iPad Pro to
$1,500 then they're likely also going to
raise a price of the 10.9 in iPad air
while introducing an even more expensive
12.9 in air to help fill that big gap
and of course the iPad Pros are likely
going to come with more storage on top
of that to help justify The increased
price price and give it more value and
probably it's going to depend on the
software Direction and what you're going
to be able to do with it and then that
right there is going to allow the whole
iPad lineup to get more expensive
including the iPad Mini kind of like
what we saw with the iPad 10 that got a
huge price increase but honestly with
the prices going up across the entire
lineup I'm starting to worry that it's
just getting too high for consumers to
handle even myself looking at the iPad
Pro 11 in at $800 that's a lot of money
I decided just to go with the iPad mini6
instead for that nice iPad experience
and get a Macbook for all the other
stuff I want to do so that right there
is why Apple's working on a 12.9 in iPad
Air mainly to fill the price gap between
the air and the crazy crazy expensive
iPad Pro coming sometime next year and
we haven't even started talking about
the potential foldable iPad Ultra that
might be even more expensive but we'll
save that for another video so let me
know your thoughts on all these crazy
iPad Air and iPad Pro leaks down in the
comment section below subscribe above if
you haven't already forgive me for my
voice definitely check out one of those
two videos right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video